to ask our neuroscientist we want to
know during different functions which
neurotransmitter chemical in chemical
perspective view what type of
neurotransmitters what released and in
which brain area and the fall and the
release for how long or how fast we
could dynamics of the neurotransmitters
everything unknown so far I pick couple
of DNA sequence of our dopamine censors
inserted it into the embryos of the
fruit fly and as an eye risk up the
embryo and ricotta transgenic animal the
fruit fly with our sensor in its brain I
come up with an idea that the fruit fly
loves fruit so firstly I just give the
fly the smell of the fruit as you
mentioned Nana
so like when we're not fly smell the
smell the banana I I find that there is
a flash in my screen I can I can look at
those flowers and signals with my naked
eyes without any imaging process the
flesh and Sigma is relatively and that's
cool and that must have been a big aha
moment scientist oh yeah Wow is the
first aha moment in my brother's career
that's beautiful
interesting identified the whole
connectome record the whole connectome
huh and then manipulate manipulate the
whole connect them yeah okay cool you
guys heard it here get building on that
I love it you can't work on that in the
future yeah please yeah no someone's
opinion me contradict yours what is my
friend Alan it's all about your
perspective
who are we and what is the nature of
this reality Nihao everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan sockin we
are on site in the beautiful Beijing
China at pecking University School of
Life Sciences we are now going to be
talking to big tree hi Alan
hello everyone I'm big tree thanks so
much for coming on a show that you
really appreciate it thank you for you
my team here is so excited for our
conversation those who don't know big
trees bio he's a graduate researcher at
the Lee lab at Peking University School
of Life Sciences using cutting edge
neurobiology to study memory and you can
find the links in the bio below ok
victory let's start things off by asking
one of our favorite questions what are
your thoughts on the direction of our
world our direction of our war if you
mean that if the hell human community
I think our direction in stones and Mars
the next color is place for us because
recently I'm writing the power biography
of Eleanor so he point out that our next
direction is a must
yeah yeah is it Ashley Vance's his
writing yes yeah yeah okay that book
yeah yeah did you read that it's such a
good book it's a really good book it's a
very inspirational book yes yeah okay
why yeah go ahead go ahead I was gonna
happen to her so so why is our direction
seen till the time since well steer on
the earth personally I think we need to
enjoy our life and taking our
responsibilities support myself support
my family and if I got bigger power I
can support my friend
and like you and for our whole society
or for our whole community making it a
better world to living yeah that is our
goal yeah yeah
I love the mentality of being pure and
being loved and achieving some sort of
our own maximal potential that earns us
some power that we can wield health in a
healthy way and also in a way that
enables us to earn and then fulfill
ourselves our families our communities
our country in the world at large like I
love that mentality and it's also
interesting that you pick Mars because
you pick that answer because we have so
many Grand Challenges to figure out on
earth and we have to also be careful to
not just export the same problems to
Mars yeah that requires a lot of human
evolution and consciousness ascension
before we can really in a healthy way be
able to colonize another celestial body
although it is a great idea to to
continue the process of doing so as we
scale civilization and hopefully have
billions of more people that are able to
enjoy consciousness creativity meaning
all these types of things what about
your journey you know my yeah let's not
first on a personal journey were worried
bored how do you pick up your interest
in science huh so I was born in
Chongqing southwestern part of China and
I'm very proud to be a challenging
artists that is such a beautiful city
and we are famous for hotpot hotpot and
we are famous for our spicy food
I love them I cannot I cannot live live
my life without without chili actually I
hate spicy food every day so even while
I live in Beijing so I was born here and
I my first 80 years I just go to the
kindergarten primary school middle
school and high school and I after the
college entrance exam I pick up my next
station in Hunan University how did you
get your interest in science though when
you are younger because yeah because you
ended up studying science in college but
how did you you know how do you know
that so I I did not know I picked
biology as my major in my university
kiss at that time I do I actually I
don't have too much understanding of
what if science are but I don't know
what I don't want I do not want to study
for my career or in my in my future
because it's very interesting
my my my family work in like my grandpa
works as a journalist like you to
interview a lot of persons and my mother
is a dinner for a newspaper so I know of
the work of the work what they do and
and but I actually I don't know too much
about the science and the engineering I
just want you open my heart hardened in
that stage I want to look at how the
world the world works in in the
scientific way or in the engineering way
so I pick up the biology as my major and
there are you know there other there are
other majors like the mass like the
physics chemistry
and also our an engineering field and
why I do not pick those few that's my
major because firstly math and physics
is very difficult I must admit that they
are difficult and when I was in middle
school or in high school I'm good at
biology and I still think it is
complicated the most complicated things
in the whole universe how they're so far
people only find life on our earth
instead of other planet so life is
complicated and there is a lot of things
to be answer and so it moved to my so I
select that College as my major and what
it even complicate in our life that has
our brain how the how a lot of neurons
talking together to each other and the
fulfill our emotion or logic and our
soul and I mean our spirit ok so so so
my after got the better degree in
biology in my university I won't I
so in my graduate school I selected the
neuroscience as my as my interest used
to further studies so it's very
interesting that I I I attend a summer
school in peak University when I was a
sophomore year graduate student and at
that time and I need to pick which field
you are interested in firstly I did not
pick the neuroscience field as wealth of
selections like the structural
biologists which are neighbor to my
University is very good at and the
second
the second direction is the stem cell
the at that time the IPS just got the
Nobel Prize
so stem cell VII is very it's very hot
at that time and the certifcate the
neural and neuroscience so firstly I
picked up the stem cell as my first
choice but but it but at that time I got
summer I got an internship study in the
I need to do Y field study in in another
area of China and cannot go through
Beijing at that time so I talked to you
that I talked to them ta whether I can
change another direction so there is
only 12 left in the neuroscience field
and so I pick up the neuroscience that
that that is how it worked
girls for me and so I pick up the
neuroscience as my direction at that
summer school and I need to select OPI
to read his papers and come and have
dinners with the PI and even visit the
lab and that got in her ship experience
in the lab so at that time and there you
know there is a huge there is a lot of
pies in the neuroscience field in
picking University and a lot of them not
very famous and successful like Ariel
and like hangzhou like transiently and
lofty pies and we alone just started
that is in Tucson asserting we'll just
start his lab at Tucson 12 so he's very
young P I so people people just people
just because I am the person who switch
to this direction so a lot of the very
famous and successful PI's has been
selected as by other students so I have
no choice so yellow is the only one who
got so I
the only slot from the neuroscience
direction and I got down installed from
it we lost love so I come to know is
real long and now his study and in my
graduates to I his he becomes my PhD
advisor so I already worked with him for
more than five years so that is my way
that is how I go to the lab and go here
the graduate school and start my study
and yes and why I'm interesting biology
neuroscience yeah and on a trajectory to
tackle the potentially the most complex
thing that we know of in the universe
what's happening in the human brain and
maybe maybe you know on the process of
going through building tools which we're
gonna talk about on tackling this big
challenge we can do massive things like
augment our health extend our longevity
make ourselves smarter make ourselves
more knowledgeable less ignorant all
this type of stuff okay it's funny the
last lot the last slide and it's a good
day
you know PKU is just this says like you
were describing there's just so many
really great P ice here and you have a
really good opportunity to be doing what
could be worldwide world-class research
that worldwide makes a big influence on
other people picking up and using the
tools which is huge let's talk about the
the first part of your work when was the
the work your work with GPCR the
g-protein coupled receptors when was the
first one the dopamine that so my first
when I joined the lab or love just start
the new project developing
GPCR based your trust me nursing service
so sure I talk about something about why
we need that are exactly let's actually
even let's take let's baby step our way
through this
so first is g-protein coupled receptors
GPC are a large protein family of
receptors that detect molecules outside
the cell yes and activate internal
signal transduction pathways the
cellular response so outside of the cell
are GPC are receptors yes that then take
information from outside the cell to
trigger the cells response gene
expression these types of things okay
and apparently you long was teaching us
on the show forty to fifty percent of
all fda-approved drugs are targeting the
gpcr receptors okay so this is a very
important dummy triggering cellular
response is crucial in biology and
neuroscience so yeah walk us through
some of the yeah the GPC are stuff to
start and then yeah why let's talk about
why that's important first so our brain
is not like it's complicated it's not
like other tissues some see happens in
the cells that can explain how we how
everything goes like in the stem cells
or in the or in our like other system
circular systems also narsings what
makes our brain might magic is that the
brain consists of a lot of neurons and
they known your eyes working alone but
they work together so communication is
the most critical function of our
nervous system of our neurons people and
the neurons need to communicate so the
major media is as
neurotransmitters which released from
the upstream we called presynaptic
neuron released in your transmitters
through their process in empty neurons
and the person is sick synaptic neuron
receives a signal and knows what's going
on what was the order and what I need to
do in the next step so this is we called
synaptic transmission and the receptors
for all of the neurotransmitters we in
our body we have its specific receptor
that is the GPC are receptors so
basically GPCR defines the major
communication function of our brain so
study GPCR is quite important but and
now people have no idea
in the living animals when and where and
actually there are more than 100 types
of neurotransmitter has been identified
and that there are even larger group
family of the corresponding GPCR
receptors and so more than 100 new your
trust me neurotransmitters have been
identified yes oh my gosh yes but you
can apply like the Pareto distribution
like a power law distribution you can
say that 20% of the of the
neurotransmitters account for 80% of all
neurotransmission like majority is
serotonin dopamine norepinephrine
Jedrek yes yeah okay and like the
there's like the long tail which is very
small occasional uses of the other 80%
yes are rarely yes that's the truth okay
okay so there are some major
transmitters and as you said something
Leslie used in our brain bow off them so
so in the chemical aspect of view or
branch so complicated even the
communication so complicated so so we
won't use that so
different neurotransmitters get involved
in different brain functions like when
you are thinking you are looking at me
and you are you are nodding everything
it is it's controlled by your nervous
system so different neurotransmitters
get involved in different functions and
and so to ask our neural scientists we
want to know during different functions
which neurotransmitter chemical in
chemical perspective view what type of
neurotransmitter was released and in
which brain area and the fall and the
release for how long or how fast we
could dynamics of the neurotransmitters
everything to unknown so far so so so we
want to know how can we detect those
neurotransmitters actually some the the
electrophysiologist
or the chemistry chemists already
developed some technologies to detect
the neurotransmitters in human brain or
in the mode playing of model organisms
and but unfortunately they are the lack
some sort of temporal resolution because
they collect the simple like in every 5
minutes or 10 minutes that is much more
slower than you're thinking Daniel logic
and and so so some of them lacks the
temporal resolution some of them lacks
the spatial resolution cuts they need to
insert a relative big electrode into the
brain to detect those signals so the
brain and so those electrode and a much
bigger than the nearest or even
comparing the
synapses which is much more smaller than
your house so the electrodes are too big
so we don't know exactly where this
different neurotransmitter released so
in the specter of temporary solution
spatial resolution there is also
chemical identities as I mentioned more
than 100 neurotransmitters was involved
in different functions
so people lacks the technology to
identify the transmitter type just based
down their electro or chemical feature
or electrophysiological feature or
electrochemistry features so biology
question need to answer by biology to
biological tools so that is what we
think why we start as our biologist what
we can do to develop new tools to answer
this old questions so so our nature has
evolved for billions of years and we got
those neurotransmitters and we also
evolved their corresponding receptors
Zayas that is how the in how the nature
detected different neurotransmitters
that hated GPCRs so we folks on their
native receptors to develop our native
detectors that is our basic logic and so
one so the gpcr from previous studies
people ready got nobel prize for solving
the structure of GPCR and we were found
that one specific neurotransmitter binds
with the GPCR that you'll be sir just
tweet a little bit that we called
conformational change yeah and
we expected that if we can if we can
attached a just fluorescent protein into
this G VCR and during the trip the
tweeting of the GBC are the fluorescent
protein twit weighted and the there
might be we can there might be some
fluorescent change and in this way which
means for a chemical signal into a light
signal so we can detect it by the very
cutting-edge imaging tools like the two
photon comes photo or a lot of new image
cutting light sheet along the image into
us yes okay so let's do that talk too
much so good such a good break down for
us a very good break down okay so let's
start with this point so we were talking
about how we have GPCR receptors on the
outside of cells and on the outside of
the neuron especially on the the post
synaptic side on so on the receiving end
of the neurotransmission there has to be
gpcr receptors because they detect the
neurochemical yes okay and then you guys
figure out how to add fluorescence to
the GPCR receptor yes okay uh-huh
through what through what engine through
what engineering enable stuff yeah oh so
that is what we call pruning engineering
work that is the multi Co most critical
process during a sensors development we
we will pick up those we amplify those
genes which encode the GPCRs from our
human genome from our human tienes we
clone those that use a technology called
PCR polymerase chain reaction we got a
DNA encoding those GBC are and then we
can use some enzymes to split it into
like two or three different segments and
then you got some slot to dude and and
you got you like you got like one slot
if you cut it you cut it this way you
got one slot and then I clumb we clone
the fluorescent protein from a jellyfish
yes from Jellyfish the green fluorescent
proteins from the jellyfish the red
fluorescent proteins from the coral so
we cloned the fluorescent protein from
the coral or from the jellyfish and we
got that uni fragment and we insert the
DNA fragment into the GPCR slot and that
this repart comes together was sealed by
some enzymes and the way in this way we
got the whole DNA sequence for
neurotransmitter sensors actually you
cannot just do it that way and God a
very perfect sensor with cute expression
level with good fluorescence even with Q
signal-to-noise ratio you need to you
need to engineer very carefully where to
insert the fluorescent protein into that
you can see our backbone and you need to
also engineer the linkers the the linker
protein or DNA sequence between them
that will defines how efficient how the
efficient of the so called
formation or change transfer from GBC
art to the fluorescent protein there
might be some linkers so you need to
tweet you need to do we call it random
notation to the Slinker sequence to see
which amino acid is the perfect
and after that we'll also engineers do
some mutations within the GPCR we call
the the neurotransmitter is very small
that will bind with some specific place
within the GPCR we called binding pocket
and within the binding pocket DNA
sequence were all amino acid sequence
were defines affinity between sensor or
between GC are ways neurotransmitter
so we're also engineer some sort of a
specific site within the binding pocket
to God the perfect sensor ways with good
spatial temporal not now with fast
kinetics with goo signal-to-noise ratio
to transfer the chemical signal into
fluorescent signal and yes there is a
lot of work if you are a first-year
graduate student just started to do such
kind of we call it protein engineering
you take like three days or today unlike
three days to get such a construct and
the test of whether it works or not and
took us a perfect sensor probably you
need to try more than 1000 alternatives
to God a perfect construct and you need
to that that is a lot of work but but we
we figure out some way to do it parolee
so that can save some time but it's
still a lot of work for a graduate
student to got such a perv
sensor and actually I'm very lucky when
I join the lab we already got those
sensors some our prior student in order
I've already pewter sensors and tested
those two sensors the most simple modal
cultured cells artificial cultured cells
in the medium sales in the medium we
tested those sensors and where I know
that big works and one so so it turns to
me I I take the job to create transgenic
animals to test whether their the
sensors can whether there's this sensor
can be used for in vivo studies in
intact animals in the living brain
during specific behavior so I took the
fruit fly for science we call Drosophila
melanogaster to as an animal model fruit
fly has been used at the model organism
for more than at least 100 years from
organ and who got after genetic screen
after new agencies he got the white eyes
white white high fly and I think that is
a star of the fly genetics so people use
fly to study the to study the biology
for a lot of years why people use fly
that is because fly is very easy and so
firstly flies very easy to do genetic
manipulations if you you cannot clone
you cannot do gene manipulation on
humans but if you want to create a
transgenic mouse or rat it takes half
half a year half a year to go such an
transgenic animal if you want to do
transgenic manipulation and
higher modem agreements like monkeys it
takes several years like once every just
several years together transitioning
animal but if you want to test is a fly
within one month you can get thousands
of different mutants that is very fast
to study the biology from with genetic
tools so we start from and that is the
first thing for the benefit to use fly
as an animal model the second thing that
even for especially for Neuroscience
field the fly brain is quite small and
there is less neuron in the brain its
brains less complicated
comparing with mammals so it is a
simpler model to study very conserved
functions of the nervous system which
the things we shared between our humans
with other animals even as more other
fruit flies like people already done a
very beautiful work use fly in the
nervous system to study like the
circadian clock the daily life which
shares between humans and flies and the
first mutant of the circadian is
identified by Seema bender at Caltech in
1970s in the fruit fly instead of human
or rat or mouse so fly is a very just
perfect model organism to study in the
nervous system to study conserve the
biological functions in the nervous
system so and again for in the
perspective of Nursing in the
perspective of neurotransmitters we
share most of the major
neurotransmitters our human has
acetylcholine glutamate gaba dopamine
norepinephrine a journaling and of those
the transmitter is existing the fly ran
and the conchos major functions so so
you have to then figure out how to
engineer the the gpcr sensor to light up
the fly brain for even a specific
neurotransmitter so you want to know
when it's sick when your receipt when
the nert when the neurotransmitter that
you're receiving on when you're sent
when you're sensing dopamine versus
serotonin versus norepinephrine etc you
need to know which one you the flying
that's what's going yeah yeah yeah sure
yeah so you have to engineer the sensor
to let you know which one so that way
when you're so bringing the banana peel
to the fruit fly and the fruit fly
smells the banana peel because yeah cuz
that's you know just like with us - were
very similar when we smell some food
it's big yeah neural activity happening
cuz that's that's our that's our
sustenance that's how we live that's how
our genes can live on and we eat so same
thing proof I've been you have to know
we have to you have to know what
neurotransmitters is being secreted
being in flow in the in the brain its
activity yeah yeah that's what I do I
give so when I get into the lab we
already got the first dopamine sensors
probably the first one in the world so I
pick couple of teeny sequence of our
dopamine sensors inserted it into the
embryos of the fruit fly and as I
reached up the embryo and the Gaza
transgenic animal the fruit fly with our
sensor in its brain so so so I'm in the
hole now
not in the hello many neurons how many
has the sensor Express mmm
that that that defines the firstly I
just test our sensors because it's a
dopamine sensor so I expressed our
dopamine censoring all of the
dopaminergic neurons in the fly brain in
how many how many let me see probably
used to 100 several hundred your ass in
the fly brain and you were all imaging
several hundred neurons over time and
spatially yes either two-photon
microscopy or
con con fuoco confocal microscopy okay
yes either one of those are one of those
work better for it a full in vivo
imaging in animal brain people you only
use two-photon microscopy compared to
photon can't see much deeper in the
brain compared with ways they can focus
so cuz I knew brains relatively deep so
people use two photon so it's very
interesting I got those transgenic
animals expressing dopamine sensor in
like several hundred dopamine neurons in
the fly brain and at first lit at first
I have no idea where should i do cat
where whether there is really dopamine
release in the fly brain and the weather
our sensor is capable to give us the
fluorescence signal so I have a no idea
at the enough law I just look at the
screen of our microscope and cannot
figure out what to do next I can see
some fluorescent signals but there is no
dopamine release no fluorescent change
and so I I just I I come out with on the
earth at the fruit fly loves fruit so
firstly I just give the flight of
mell of the fruit as you mentioned
banana so like when when the fly smell
does smell the banana III I find that
there is a flash in my screen I can I
can look at those words and signals with
my naked eyes without any imaging
process the fluorescence signal is
relative B and that's cool and that must
have been a big aha moment for a
scientist of yeah wow this is the first
aha moment in my graduate career it's
beautiful so and actually it's not all
of the dopaminergic neurons or off the
sensors in the fly brain is just like
subsets like several like less than 100
listen 100 neurons in the fly brain get
activated and I just look at those
signals with my naked eyes and when I
come back to my computer to analyze
those signals and I found oh those
things are really works it's the first
time we got know that our sensor cannot
only be used for culture sales but also
to study the real biology how animal
smell things
yes and it's it's complicated but it's
also as simple as taking the genetically
encoded sensor and embedding it in the
embryo of the fruit fly uh-huh and then
having that embryo divide and divide and
divide and divide vitamin and make the
fruit fly thousands of the fruit fly no
no because they multiply really fast
after you have one yeah like that breeds
because the first fly and give will make
new babies and
of the new babies carried our new
sensors they carry the sensors yes Wow
and so then after just a couple months
see you have thousands of flies with the
earth your two sensors okay and then the
fly has to you know be that that safe
glue has to be used to keep it on the on
the foil or the paper so that you I
think you must talk with some fly person
previously do you do long mentioned it
on the show oh you have to have a safe
non-harmful glue yes to keep the fruit
fly on the we call it chamber the image
and the imaging chamber yet you mount
the flies and we use wishes
Twitter's to open a very small window on
the fly's head and expels the brain but
in not touch and you know her the brand
keep the brain intact and let the fly
think air everything it won't you think
yes oh really so you can use very small
tweezers to open the fruit fries bring
just a little bit and not not just a
little bit wait a bit but my eyes I do
not touch I do not touch the bread I do
I open up the cuticle or your skin off
the setting of the head and dispose
explain that the two-photon microscopy
can go past the skin yes more easily to
the brain yeah and then the bananas
brought up yes and then you were looking
at the two-photon microscopy and then
you see the as the fruit fly smells the
tiny little pieces of banana and you see
the fluorescence of about a hundred
or so of your yeah let some light lights
up of the neurons yes that have the
dopamine sensors yes attached to them
that yeah yeah genetically encoded these
sensors from the embryo until that's how
this is this is an excellent scientific
advancement that has so much potential
thank you yeah kiss yes kiss one big
problem in previously that when people
also want to detect the different like
event dopamine signals in the fly brain
people can use electrophysiology method
to record electrical signals from single
neuron but as I mentioned there are a
lot of neurons in the fly brain and
people cannot record it one by one
because it takes a lot of time to do
even one recording and if you want to go
through off the neurons it's almost
impossible but for imaging method we can
just open a window and look at all of
the neurons at the same time and within
several second we can know which one is
working which one is not is silent and
we can do it all we can recall off
different neurons parallely that is the
benefit of the imaging comparing with
previous electro chemical method and the
imaging has has so you can put say the
image method has high throughput and
and yeah yeah yeah Wow now now no you
want to create sensors for all of the
other important especially
neurotransmitters yes okay yeah that's
what I'm doing and I already keep I
think our sensors already cover major
neurotransmitters in existing the fly
brain including dopamine serotonin
acetylcholine and the adrenaline of the
fruit fly caught dopamine and no way
events which to with where I start to
develop other are the non major
neurotransmitters we call it in your
peptide but they are very important and
the neuropeptide contribute to like 80
percent of the neurotransmitters
identified in the brain but previous
people just got no way to observe those
moment results and it we are very lucky
cuz our method can be trans can be also
adopted to develop sensors not only for
the major neurotransmitters small
because small molecule neurotransmitters
but also for other types of
neurotransmitters and this method is
universal so we are lucky now we are
working on that to explain the with the
sensor palette and we want to cover as
more at major near asthma asthma near
transmitter as possible where else can
the
genetically encoded sensors for GPCR
sites be useful because the brain is a
very useful place for this can all those
other cells on our body also use the
similar techniques for especially
pharmacology if so many of the
fda-approved drugs are for targeting
gpcr receptors then shouldn't we also
have sensors on those gpcr receptor
sites so that we know if the
pharmacology is actually connecting with
the targeted cells that is what we are
that has one potential application for
our sensors to screen for new drugs
because during pharmacology in I know in
the in the pharmacologic field or in
that companies people won't you screen
for different drugs that can target
GPCRs as you mentioned but what people
are recalling is actually the downstream
signaling of native gpcr because
downstream of the countryman signal
range of different gvr's
and then that takes time and and after
and then that takes time that is one
disadvantage and the second disadvantage
is that people don't know there is an
amplification in fact of the downstream
signals so people don't know to what
extent the gpcr is real activated or
inhibited so with our sensors we attach
the fluorescent protein on two different
GPC ours and ricardo sensor and this
fluorescent protein just this
fluorescent signal just count from that
UCR itself so we can quantitatively and
the to screen for the chemicals and the
potential drugs which can activate or
inactivate different [ __ ] ours and in a
very fast in a very high throughput that
is our benefit and
potential at the vet of the occasional
fire sensor and then actually we are
where where they start to try on that
project
excellent excellent it seems like
especially with the vast amount of money
that the pharmaceutical industry spends
on drug design and development that it
would be really helpful to increase
efficacy of knowing if they hit the
targeted cells with your sensors yes
yeah using your sensors for that process
now let's talk about the work with
memory uh-huh sure
because when the fruit fly mm-hmm smells
the banana uh-huh and we see the neural
activity and we map it spatially
temporally uh-huh then that becomes a
memory that the fly holds no it doesn't
interesting okay that is not the memory
I mention I think you mean what is what
do you mean is more like similarity or
familiarity
yes okay you you smell something in the
you smell it all the time and you just
get desensitized with that smell and you
no longer pay attention to that smell
that we caused a familiarity well maybe
more so that my all of our collective
human ancestry has for the last millions
of years been smelling food and when we
smell food from a million years ago we
figured out okay I smelled this food it
tastes good then several hundred
thousand years ago I smell it tastes
good ten thousand years ago I smell it
tastes good you know even up until now
oh you we still smell it it tastes good
so it's like literally in code
in millions of years of memory you mean
the human the native preference to a
smell which is evolved during the
history during human evolution and that
is one kind of memory encoding we can
call a native memory and gonna be in
your dream and in this case I would also
be a native memory encoded in the fruit
fly right yes this native memory will
also encode in the fruit fly that is why
fruit like a fruit fly can see like
fruit so what I call is we I'm studying
the associative memory that's a lot more
complicated yes yeah our brain works so
much differently than a computer does in
the sense of associative memory versus
storing a file in a very specific place
that can only be accessed by going to
that specific place in the computer
memory whereas with us it's so
associative did I start talking about my
visit to Peking University I'll start
thinking about all of the science you
were teaching all the people that I was
meeting all the cultural experience yes
so associative yeah that that is the
associative memory so the fruit fly is
not as dumb as you think the fruit flies
relative smart and the fruit fly can
link the smell was with previous
experience and if the experience is
harmful or it's a punishment the next
time after the after a bridging the
connection the next time when the fly
smell the same other it knows to get a
voice from that and if the experience is
something clear like the food the fly
learned you can approach you that other
this phenomenon has been identified for
like more than 50 years has happened
by Seema bender a professor in Caltech
in 1970s and the people study this field
from half after half century study
people already know that a lot of
neurotransmitters take part in this
critical function include among them
including dopamine serotonin
acetylcholine octo coming of the
neurotransmitters we already got sensors
and we do not intentionally create our
sensors to fit this specific neural
circuitry but now we previous people
know that flies with with abnormal
neurotransmitters like dopamine
serotonin it cannot form such type of
associative memory or the they forget
more quicker or the or the we see it has
deficit in long-term memory or they just
can can only remember the goossens but
cannot remember the negative things so
the fly experience different deficit of
associative memory weighs the loss of
different neurotransmitters people
already know that from behavior studies
to test whether the fly go or no go to
different smell so but no one has ever
know which when and where does different
neurotransmitter was released even here
in the Association yeah and during the
memory recall and this is really
interesting for a lot of our current
neurological diseases specifically like
depression and anxiety and and ADHD PTSD
yes what we treat is just a PTSD in the
fibrin and we want to see what happens
during the PTSD during the PTSD
happening and what happens when the fly
just experience it once again how to we
track we could retrieve those memories
in their brain yeah in their deeper mind
yes Wow yeah it seems as though if a if
we can approximate that a human to a
monkey to a mouse to a fish to a fruit
fly is at least somewhat similar there
may be a a pretty serious discovery
awaiting us that says something along
the lines of if there is a lack of
neurotransmission occurring where there
is supposed to be when it's supposed to
happen for especially when you're doing
some sort of a task that usually gets
you neurotransmission like a reward like
a behavior that usually gets you a
reward like in the case of people with
depression it's like if you get out of
the house and go and exercise or go and
read a book or go and do something meet
with friends do something that is it
drives you closer to your goals if
you're not getting the same
neurochemical flows
that you should be that's a big problem
mm-hmm that's it yeah that's why we want
to study this phenomenon cuz the
associative memory is just so it's the
learning ability is some critical
ability should you just push our human
life or push our history forward so and
we and what is very interesting that all
of those amico chemicals used in the fly
brain to form the memory or to forget a
specific memory
it's just conserved between humans with
the Flies and the humans also used since
like dopamine serotonin and
acetylcholine to kill the memory to form
the memory and so the study in the free
flight will give us a lot of hint of
what's going on in our brain and how we
can treat ourselves in case of anything
bad happens if our memory encoding
system is having issues with
neurochemical flows then there may be a
much better specifically targeted way of
doing stimulation to reintroduce those
original neurochemical flows to continue
people in the direction of when I do
something when I'm supposed to get a
neurochemical release then I actually
get it then straight stimulation is a
very interesting field that has a lot of
you know ultrasound
electrical stimulation magnetic
stimulation a lot of interesting very
careful stimulation is very important
very precise stimulation is very
important but healing people was very
important healing people bringing people
back to their their their their
healthiest and most creative flow states
the being is very important sure you've
heard do you feel like that's like one
of your main reasons why your study like
what are the main reasons why you are
studying the memory like healthy and
happy for humans or what my study of
memory yes it's just curious I tripped
by curiosity the memory created the
person defines our defines our identity
defines who we are people can not can
cannot connect itself which if people
cannot connect it itself with previous
experience you just feel lonely and they
feel abandoned by the world or by the
community because like something like
you know the people will withheld
Hamer's disease we will forget
everything it just experienced and
that's sad and and so four people lost
the memory we I don't know what's the
feeling of the loss of memory but I know
what's the feeling when I face a person
who lost his memories Abe and AD
patience and just my grandma and I feel
I have no way to help her but that's sad
because the current science cannot help
people place AD but I want probably
there is a way to figure it out by the
study of how memory was formed how
memory was lost and I do not want to
have that experience when I getting out
and possible that is a deep drive of why
I'm pursuing that question yeah and we
like to use the analogy of the library
you have the big library in your in your
brain and that you experience
neurodegeneration and the library books
are on fire in the library losing big
volumes of yes of memory and you know
sleep is another really good way to
understand memory that everything that
we experience today we sleep so that we
can integrate everything today with our
last for me 26 years of my life
uh-huh and that when you have issues
with sleep or when you have issues with
encoding memory you lose it would be so
cool for for us to could we could we
remember all of the cool things that we
experienced today but no we're not we're
only gonna experience we're only gonna
remember certain key things yeah from
today yeah we're gonna encode with our
last 26 years uh-huh but what if I
wanted to come back to the exact part in
this interview
from you know what we have huh we have
our recording of it which enables us to
do exactly that come back to this exact
point uh-huh that's why we do things
like record great conversations so we
can do exactly that and share it uh-huh
but if we weren't recording it and I
really wanted to come back to that
sentence for that paragraph that you
said that was really inspiring to me
mm-hmm
so for me to be able to go back for us
to be able to have really cool recording
of our entire day of our entire life
stream of memory and to be able to go
back fast-forward rewind pause it's very
interesting I like that a lot and it can
more easily be stored that content then
the entire life of big tree okay or the
entire life of even your grandmother
before the neurodegeneration happens
that we could capture our memories
mm-hm and then be able to go back and
like see what life was like for her oh
you know and that type of pretty
interesting field of upcoming study with
memory and and the retention of
knowledge and the transmission of
knowledge over time mm-hmm
yes that's very important interesting
and I think what we want to keep is what
you mean keep the memory or keep the
moment is keeping the state of how the
neurons unconnected now interesting how
they're connected in what is
transmitting how uncle's basically the
chemo electro connectome yes okay yes of
that exact time period that we were
talking about those exact
15 seconds of you reading that paragraph
yes I need the chemo electrode
connectome of that 15 second period yes
probably you can copy those click
play button and then I sort of felt like
probably that's a way how you can go
back and then loose yeah it just feels
like exactly the same way and see the
things here the same feeling the wing
that the air this mail yeah
that's a way interest how you're on
communicate anything yeah you feel yeah
okay what about your ideal neuroscience
tool oh my ideal in the Earth's last two
we were just talking about like this you
know chemo electro connectome right or
what would be your ideal neuroscience
tool that would help you do exactly what
we are striving to achieve in the field
of neuroscience maybe fifty or a hundred
years down the line what will that tool
look like that will enable us to do
everything that we want today with
neuroscience that must be there must be
one only one to four as the best tool to
study the neuroscience questions for
such kind of tool firstly you keep the
whole brain intact but you can get the
whole information of the activities of
different murals with without any
perturbation you don't need to open the
brain
you don't need to you don't need to cut
a window and you just got all of the
neural activity all the chemical flows
in the brain simultaneously from every
neuron and in people on the top of that
you got the identity of which neuron you
are looking at the identity what I mean
identity is
genetic background of the numeral which
gene etiquette it expressed and which
RNA is transcribed and with that you
already know you can do off the
recording things and plus another thing
you need to you can't get access to
manipulate every activity you can either
turn on the neuron turn off the neuron
and all turn thousands of billions
neural simultaneously to see whether you
can you can drive a real function with
the activity of a combination of the
matrix of the neurons so that that is a
that so for such kind of two so let me
summarize it you need to know the
identity of the cell where it is and
which gene which RNA is transcribed and
expressed and then you can't recall
every neuron activity and then you can
manipulate every neuron activity yes yes
but there's no such a true yeah I like
that ideal tool yes yeah it gives us
that big vision absolutely people push
our car the human technology from this
three aspect orthogonal but there is no
such a tool which can give you even two
type of function together no one no such
kind to now they can even do two of
those no I don't think so
isn't there something that is doing both
readout of electrical activity and
stimulation
nothing's doing both right now read out
and
manipulation people can achieve such
kind of stuff was to to combine
technology so you had to combine - yes
but ok interesting but to turn that into
even one yeah yeah okay and what was the
third one served one so identity
identify uh-huh recall and the metaphor
didn't manipulate yes interesting
identified the whole connectome record
the whole connectome uh-huh and then
manipulate manipulate the whole connect
dump yeah okay cool you guys heard it
here
get building on that I love it you can't
work on that in the future yeah please
yeah yeah in orthogonal II I like that
at the same time tackling at the same
time how can we inspire more people
around the world to work together
learn English that is the first step for
everyone to communicate and after
communication and then you can work
together you can disagree you can agree
but you know what to do next but if you
if you don't talk to each other there's
nothing happens I'm just kidding so
communication is crucial yes yes one
will get off the people United to work
for one goal and to overcome our current
challenge
I don't think various session so there
is such a thing which can convert
everyone United and keep and the work on
one thing to overcome some problem that
is not the way how human or animal was
divine to you every life lives for its
own benefit that is how gene tell us to
do not for the others you know gene
selfish so we just we just but the self
achievement has different aspect someone
achieved in the science someone in
business and one in arts so that makes
how the how the earth a versatile place
or the human community of versatile
place and is reeled in different aspect
and that is why our Earth's are
beautiful we understand where we can
every colorful we got colorful view we
got colorful life
yeah what do you think is the overall
meaning or purpose of life
what what do you think we asked the or
officer can you give me some
inspirations
ones that I've really enjoyed are to
understand the source code source Co of
our reality okay and then to maximize
flourishing maximize creativity
consciousness uh-huh-huh and then to
take that source code that we understand
and create more life from that initial
source code and let it evolve again to
complexity so complete the circle well
yeah there just to complicate in my mind
the purpose of our life from the from
the nervous system it tells us the
purpose for life is just a seeking for
dopamine people one people trying to get
reward from enjoying simple things like
enjoying the food in joining a love
relationship in joining in joining the
various side view and from a higher
level people work people devote itself
to the things they love and to fulfill
themself that is that is another
addiction every addiction is a pursuit
for dopamine when there is no dopamine
in in your brain you feel no meaning of
your life that's what I think
interesting interesting even the most
meditative people on the planet do you
think they still live for dopamine sure
I think just they are pursuing some like
philosophy way stunt and very searching
for some missing the real meaning of the
world and everything will make himself
or make her make himself or make herself
feel
oh I'm the smartest person in the world
that we called self achievement and this
at that moment that you can if you put
and grab sensory it's mine in his or her
mind you will think there's a lot of
dopamine but the person may be doing it
with no agenda they may just be being
meditative without the agenda to be the
most enlightened you mean must be very
silent and a night crawler is I get to
ask you maybe I did why do you why do
you call it the grab sense o then crabs
in there it's because you can think we
catch up the dynamics of the different
neurotransmitters in the brain so grab
is written it's mimicking so the behave
of catching some signal all do so okay
so you guys call your your your
genetically encoded sensor that goes on
the word the GPCR took fluoresce uh-huh
you guys call that grabbing because it's
grabbing the neurotransmitter
yes coming yes you guys called grab
sensors okay good to know good soon okay
and then what's one skill that every
child should know going into the
exponential technology age for the 21st
century skill
probably it's good to learn some coding
it's learn some coding to to to solve
the problems which can not be solved
with single hand you need to think
things synchronously and work things
think erroneously
with a huge amount of data because we
already got a huge hundreds of thousands
get gigabytes of data at the same time
with our modern technologies we need to
figure out a way to analyze that no
matter its light its sound its magnetic
or its anything it's huge the only code
can help you to solve that problem in do
you think that consciousness evolves
from the biological process do you think
it comes from somewhere
it takes its seat you mean the God
versus the nature people you can
describe it however you will not want
what do you think consciousness is and
how do you think it originates
I don't think there is real so-called
consciousness there is just the
connecting network of the nervous system
it it process informations it process
the calming information and give out the
output behavior that we call reflex
and every conscious I think it's just
can become an explained as a reflect of
our nervous system and your how but so
the next question is how the connecting
network are built for each different
individual so that depends on the
previous experience the appearance is
shapes the connection pattern of your
nervous system and if there is another
one if there is another one who has
exactly the same experience like you and
it will give every output exactly the
same like you I think that is what you
caught conscious it exists in our humans
but it also exists in lower animals like
in vertebrates even in a few days in the
plans
it's just reflect reflex yeah yeah do
you think we have free will
I used to discuss this topic with my
friend and I still have my point of no I
do not think everyone has a free will
our will is as I said defined by the
connection patterns of the brain and the
brain is shaped by the experience and
you don't Newton not you do not have an
idea or give out the behavior by
yourself
but find by your previous experience
that is you are doomed to think though
what you so have the idea or give a
behavior yeah
millions of years of behavioral
evolution for human and then billions of
years for the microbes that live inside
of us so yeah a slave to our behavioral
patterns of biology over billions of
years yes
yeah and even our last 26 years of
memory and decisions and our eyes you
think our everything in life can be
explained by chemical reactions by in
thematic activities by basic physics and
the combination of the powered physics
and chemistry defines our every behavior
and an even think and spirit everything
can be explained
even though we do not know exactly how
they work together we'll get to the
source code soon and we'll be able to
better explain every behavior hmm the
biology the chemistry oh that if that
depends on the development of new tools
that does depend on the development of
new tools yeah so please fund the lab
and other labs around the world that are
building the tools to do the scientific
probing please exactly what do you think
is the role of love in life role of love
in life you need to count you firstly
people I'm not such a person who just
grown up with an very defined direction
of what I'm going to do in the future or
next or as my creator
so I cling to my experience I think the
way to find the love is to experience to
try to come from with the exact quality
know exactly the person you want to
stick on and and and you find get along
with the people or get along with that
stuff you just feel make you feel better
and you
so this is the thing you love and people
just try try different things
last question is how about you are you
the person who know what are you going
to do before even before you try and
that do you believe something like the
destiny
yeah oh you already know that before you
test it no matter how you get it
disappointed like you want to pursue a
girl and but she just don't like you and
will you just keep on keep on going and
do that I like the word destiny there's
a lot of nuance to that word and some
say that you come with a destiny you
come with some sort of gift or gem to
unleash into the world that you are born
into I like that I think there's
something very deeply true about that
you have every one of us has a unique
potential to bring to the world it could
be that we have some sort of free will
in the sense of how much of that destiny
do we actually get to what percentage of
it we actually get to and then it could
be that maybe whether you got to 90
percent of your destiny or 60 percent of
your destiny that maybe that that was
already determined from the moment that
you're born these are interesting
questions and that's why we ask them on
the show uh-huh yeah sure the last
question yes what is the most beautiful
thing in the world
the most beautiful thing in the world is
life itself the most complicated
chemical and the fatal and physical
mathematical things happens is within
such short with such a short temper
resolution and with such small spatial
resolution all those equations comes
together to build the life life is the
most valuable thing everybody needs your
treasure
big tree yes this has been such a
enlightening episode thank you thank you
thank you so much for coming on the show
and teaching us thank you asking me so
much questions that I have never think
about that's so hard you go hard that
the cause of interesting emanation oh
what a funny quote we'll have to pull
that quote that's a good one so many
good questions harder than the college
entrance examination I love it I love it
thanks everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode let us know what you're thinking
also have more conversations with your
friends families co-workers people
online about cutting edge neuroscience
tools have more conversations around
GPCR g-protein coupled receptors more
conversations around studying memory
have more conversations around how to
run these experiments and how to best
understand that source code and make
these scientific fundamental
advancements check out the link in the
bio below to big tree check out the link
to you lonely lab org as well and
support the artists the entrepreneurs
the leaders the organizations around the
world that you believe in supports
simulation our links are below you can
find our links to our patreon paypal
cryptocurrency you can design cool merch
and get paid all those links are below
help us continue doing cool things like
coming on site to great places like
Beijing to conduct these interviews and
go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you very much thank you for tuning
in and we'll see you soon these
okay that's good
Wow think it that's really good that was
really good Yui yeah yeah it's much yeah
tons of just neuroscience knowledge and
then tons of really good back and forth
at the end around these complex
questions that was really good oh yeah
thank you so much good neuroscience
explanation you're a really good
communicator good job in English -
you're doing really well
[Music]